[Musique]
travaillait et politique ce matin c'est
aurélien pradié bonjour bonjour merci
beaucoup d'être avec nous député du lot
secrétaire général des républicains on
est ensemble pendant 20 minutes pour une
interview en partenariat avec la presse
quotidienne régionale représenté par
julien lécuyer bonjour julien bonjour
rien de la voix du nord
et on commence par cette police
sanitaire et olivier verrons qui va donc
s'exprimer cet après-midi pour détailler
expliquer la stratégie du gouvernement
dans cette lutte contre le coc vide est
ce que pour vous et le manque de clarté
cette stratégie gouvernementale
je pense qu'on peut le dire avec une
certaine évidence depuis le début elle
manque de clarté le manque de cohérence
nous l'avons vu sur la question des
masques qui tenait un sujet absolument
centrale qui a démontré à quel point le
gouvernement ne savait pas où ils
allaient et d'ailleurs vous savez si
aujourd'hui on a une telle contestation
sur la question du port du masque
généralisée il faut comprendre d'où ça
vient ça vient pas de complotisme
ambiance ça vient aussi du fait que les
mêmes dirigeants qui aujourd'hui nous
explique que le port du masque est
absolument impératif
hier nous expliquait qu' il ne fallait
surtout pas le porter et donc cette
incohérence de la parole publique
elle a créé ce grand brouillon puis
aujourd'hui moi j'ai un vrai sujet avec
les tests depuis le début de cette crise
sanitaire tout le monde nous dit tout le
monde convient que les tests sont au
coeur de la stratégie
le ministre la santé n'a pas cessé de le
répéter et depuis plusieurs mois nous
nous rendons compte que le pays n'est
pas du tout organisé pour permettre les
tests il faut être très clair
vous l'avez peut-être vu avec certaines
reproche aujourd'hui il faut attendre
dans les files d'attentes de 4 à 6
heures les uns contre les autres pour
bénéficier d'un test
il faut parfois plusieurs jours pour
obtenir le résultat vitesse qui fait que
c'est totalement inefficace priorisation
dont parle jean castex vous ayez être
favorable j'imagine bien sûr mais ça
fonctionne pas ça fonctionne pas depuis
48 heures on voit que ça marche pas
voyez les files d'attentes parisienne
voyez en province moi je le constate y
compris dans ma région
les laboratoires sont absolument
débordées et on allait reprendre la
stratégie d'aller dire aux gens allez
vous faire tester même au moindre
symptôme est de rendre les tests
gratuits ce n'était pas la bonne
stratégie
ça veut simplement dire que notre pays a
été incapable de s'organiser
c'est ça la vérité la vérité c'est que
ce gouvernement a été incapable de
mettre en place une stratégie à la
hauteur de ses moyens il a été incapable
depuis le début de cette crise sanitaire
de faire en sorte que nous ayons
notamment des techniques de test
nouvelle enfin écouter sommes dans une
grille
nation une grande puissance mondiale moi
je trouve invraisemblable pardon de le
dire que depuis le début de cette crise
on n'ait pas trouvé d'autre solution de
test que le test par le prélèvement
nasal qui pose des problèmes
enfin on a quand même un grand pays qui
auraient pu réfléchir à ces questions
s'organiser l'état aurait pu mobiliser
des moyens pour nous ayons cette
capacité de recherche et d'innovation et
quant à l'organisation opérationnelle
je suis désolé mais ce gouvernement
parle beaucoup
jean castex nous fait des grandes
phrases mais est ce qu'il faut aller le
mans mais ce crédit est ce que vous
pensez par exemple qu'il faut peut-être
reconfirmer plus en plus facilement
localement être encore plus strictes sur
les contraintes qui sont imposés aux
gens je vais être clair sur la question
des tests je pense que c'est absolument
urgentissime que le gouvernement traite
cette question là je le redis on ne peut
pas avoir des files d'attentes de quatre
à six heures avec des gens les uns
contre les autres avoir plusieurs
journées d'attentes pour les tests qu'il
faut régler prioritairement ce problème
là et il n'est pas réglé aujourd'hui
pour le reste et notamment ce que vous
évoquiez sur la territorialisation des
mesures moi je suis décentralisateur
enfin au delà des décentralisateur je
suis aussi soucieux d'une stratégie
nationale
cette épidémie elle n'est pas limitée à
certaines régions cette épidémie c'est
une épidémie qui touche l'ensemble du
pays et l'ensemble du monde et donc je
souhaite que la nation fixe un cap et
cette stratégie de jean castex qui
consiste à dire au fond au territoire
débrouillez vous moi je trouve
stupéfiant comme premier ministre 10 as
et préfet vous allez nous faire remonter
vos propositions pour organiser la
stratégie j'ai du mal à saisir monsieur
produit parce que d'un certain côté on
entend la droite qui estime qu'il faut
redonner du pouvoir aux territoires et
justement différencié pour s'adapter au
terrain local et en même temps vous ne
dites il faut une stratégie nationale
est finalement que l'état impose des
règles communes et parce que moi ma
conviction c'est que on peut être
décentralisateur sans souhaiter qu'une
stratégie qui doit être une stratégie
régaliennes se traite au niveau
départemental apprenons les questions de
sécurité publique
chacun conviendra qu'on peut être
décentralisateur et en même temps ne pas
souhaiter que la police et la
gendarmerie s'organise de manière
différenciée selon les départements
il ya des règles nationales qui doivent
être fixées la décentralisation elle n'a
de force que si elle a un cadre national
il ya des sujets sur lesquels on peut
effectivement et c'est souhaitable
donner aux territoires toute latitude y
compris sur les questions sanitaires que
nous évoquons
d'autres y avoir un cadre national
prenons un exemple très précis pour je
puisse me faire comprendre la question
des écoles aujourd'hui dans un
département comme le mien il y a une
stratégie qui peut consister dès lors
qu'il ya un cas dans une école à fermer
une seule classe dans un département
voisin le même département qui est à
quelques km la stratégie va être de
fermer toute l'école dès lors qu'il y
ait comprenez bien que cette volonté de
différencier ne veut pas être une
volonté on peut pas produire des écarts
considérables dans la stratégie je
crains que sous prétexte d'être
décentralisateur ce que ce gouvernement
n'est pas du tout un gouvernement ultra
centralisateur emmanuel macron est ultra
centralisateur derrière cet affichage là
il y ait une volonté de refiler la
patate chaude ou territoires sans les
moyens qui sont nécessaires et voilà
donc m'a réservé mon inquiétude
allez on va parler de cette rentrée ça
c'est allé cette journée de mobilisation
aujourd'hui à l'appel de la cgt pour
demander notamment des hausses de
salaires pour manifester contre les
suppressions d'emplois se trouve vous
comprenez ça tu appelle à manifester
l'appel à la manifestation n'ont donc ça
fait longtemps pour ma part que je
comprend plus très bien ce que les
organisations quelques organisations
syndicales de ce pays veulent faire et
peuvent faire mais ce que nous ne
pouvons pas ignorer notamment depuis la
crise des gis les jeunes c'est qu'il y a
dans notre pays deux sentiments grave
celui de la désespérance
je pense que notre pays désespère toutes
les catégories sociales toutes les
générations n'ont plus de cap n'ont plus
de raisons d'espérer un avenir meilleur
et ça c'est dramatique dans une
démocratie comme la nôtre est ma
deuxième chose inquiétude c'est ce
sentiment d'injustice profond
personne ne peut contester aujourd'hui
que nous avons une question sur les
salaires dans notre pays personne ne
peut contester aujourd'hui que nous
avons une vraie question sur les
injustices sociales dans notre pays et
si nous ne traitons pas si le politique
ne traite pas cette question du manque
d'espérance du manque d'espoir et de
cette présence trop forte de l'injustice
alors nous allons vers l'explosion
sociale or ça veut dire quoi monsieur
pradier ça veut dire que par exemple il
faut répondre à la revendication de la
cgt d'augmenter les salaires des
premiers de corvée comme on dit mais
nous pouvons souhaiter que
traiter la question des salaires sans
être d'accord avec la cgt vous savez la
droite républicaine à laquelle
j'appartiens
elle a toujours interrogé la question de
la justice sociale
georges pompidou le général de gaulle
était extrêmement favorable à la
question de la participation notamment
pour faire évoluer les salaires nicolas
sarkozy avait la question de la
défiscalisation des heures
supplémentaires la droite à laquelle
j'appartiens c'est une droite juste qui
est capable de poser la question des
salaires que nous devons poser dans
notre pays aujourd'hui sans pour autant
devenir des affreux cégétiste sans
vouloir dire qu'ils sont tous affreux et
donc je dis que l'un des chemins pour la
droite républicaine c'est d'être juste
et ça passe par la question des salaires
l'autre défiance qu'on peut qu on peut
noter monsieur pradier c'est le
sentiment des français que l'état ne
peut plus rien faire contre les plans
sociaux
on l'a vu avec auchan nokia et au hyères
bridgestone ou xavier bertrand autre ami
xavier bertrand a parlé même
d'assassinât le terme est quand même est
pas anodin est ce qu'on est condamné à
avoir des plans sociaux sans pouvoir
réagir c'est aussi sûrement une des
grandes raisons de désespérance dans
notre pays c'est cette forme de fatalité
depuis quand la politique n'a pas changé
la vie de nos concitoyens
depuis très longtemps depuis quand la
politique n'a pas été capable de dire
que ceux qui n'étaient pas acceptables
devait être transformée et emmanuel
macron incarne ce fatalisme font ils à
cette vision qui consiste à dire que le
politique est là pour accompagner une
marge quasi évidente du monde la
mondialisation et ses injustices les
écarts de salaires etc à justice la
concentration des richesses entre
certaines fortunes et l'écart entre les
premiers de corvée et et les autres bref
emmanuel macron il y là pour être
spectateur de cette installation d
injustice et de cette fatalité notamment
sur les plans sociaux eh bien je crois
que là aussi un des grands chemins de
responsabilité pour la droite c'est de
réincarner ce que nous avons toujours
historiquement un carnet c'est à dire un
volontarisme politique au fond qu'on ait
le courage de mettre les pieds dans le
plat et de dire cela doit être changé et
c'est aux politiques mettre les pieds
dans le plat est ce que ça veut dire
concrètement remettre en cause le
libéralisme qualité puis une fil
conducteur de la droite côté jeu
moi je veux pas utiliser des mots parce
que je sais qu'ils sont toujours source
de caricature mais le général de gaulle
parlait des forces de l'argent
georges pompidou a prononcé quelques
grands discours notamment à chicago en
1970 dans lequel il disait aux chefs
d'entreprise votre première
responsabilité les chefs d'entreprise de
savent d'ailleurs c'est une
responsabilité qui consiste à faire
progresser les hommes les femmes et les
hommes et donc je pense que l'on peut
être de droite
c'est d'ailleurs notre fil conducteur
historique sans pour autant considérer
que la valeur économique est supérieur à
la valeur humaine la grande espérance de
la droite républicaine a toujours été de
dire ce que nous voulons c'est que les
femmes et les hommes de notre pays vivre
mieux demain que ils trouvent des
raisons d'espérer et des raisons de
trouver leur bonheur
et cela passe par une nécessité
d'interroger notre économie je peux le
dire sans être taxé d'être neuf les
communistes allaient revenir dans
l'économie ce que ça veut dire
concrètement
entrée en participation de l'état dans
certaines entreprises qui sont en
difficulté
oui on m'a bridgestone ou ailleurs bien
sûr lorsque ces entreprises sont
stratégiques la droite républicaine n'a
toujours fait nous pouvons parfaitement
investir au titre de l'état mais il faut
aller plus loin je parlais de la
question des salaires tout à l'heure moi
je crois en une vraie révolution de la
participation c'est à dire que nous
devons revoir mécanismes profonds qui
nous permettent de faire en sorte que
celui qui produit des efforts soient
justement récompensés je crois en une
droite juste tout simplement
aurélien pradié vous entamé un tour de
france environnementale
est-ce qu'il ya besoin de prouver que
les républicains s'intéresse à ces
questions l'environnement de l'écologie
il y a sûrement besoin de rappeler que
la droite républicaine a historiquement
beaucoup fait sur la question de
l'environnement et là pardon de le
remettre en perspective aussi le premier
ministère de l'environnement c'est
georges pompidou le discours de
johannesbourg sur la maison qui brûle
c'est jacques chirac
le grenelle de l'environnement c'est
nicolas sarkozy c'est jean louis borloo
il ça n'a l'air de quand même d'imprimer
auprès d'eux des français il ya un
sondage ifop il vient de chez vous donc
on va pas tellement le remettre en cause
ses près de 7 français sur 10 étaient
interrogés estiment qu'aujourd'hui aucun
parti de droite n'incarne l'écologie
mais certaines loin si votre question
est de dire est ce que la droite
républicaine depuis quelques années n'a
pas oublié toutes les palettes de
composition qui pouvait être la sienne
évidemment que oui et je ne sais pas
plus qu'oublier on va écouter ce que
disait luc chatel c'est en 2016 il était
alors président du conseil national des
républicains
chers amis les républicains doivent être
le propre parti du principe d'innovation
plus que du principe de précaution
le parti du gaz de schiste le parti des
ogm
le parti des pirates est qu on ne peut
pas dire qu'elle collégiens étaient trop
car sur ce coup là luc chatel et dit
quelque chose de très intelligent non
plus pour une raison très simple si si
si je suis factuel la loi qui a été
porté sur la traduction de l'exploiteur
de l'exploration du gaz de schiste
elle a été portée notamment par
christian jacob et par la droite
républicaine à l'assemblée nationale le
premier créé la commission développement
durable à l'assemblée nationale devinez
qui c'est c'est christian jacob et c'est
la droite républicaine
donc vous avez raison de dire que
sûrement nous nous sommes égarés
sûrement que durant quelques années la
droite républicaine a oublié qu'elle
pouvait et qu'elle devait parler de ces
sujets et moi je dis on sait que laurent
wauquiez le président le précédent
président du parti n'était pas très
porté sur ces questions écologiques
c'est jugé que c'était pas la priorité
est ce que c'est lui qui vous a fait
rater le virage écolo non c'est une
responsabilité collective
je crois que la droite a cru à une
stratégie et j'y ai cru sûrement un
moment aussi qui consistait à ne parler
qu'à sa part de marché électoral
cette droite qui se dit au fond que son
avenir c'est de faire au moins 10% aux
élections
eh bien nous sommes de plus en plus
nombreux à croire que le bel avenir de
la droite c'est de faire plus de 50 %
aux élections c'est d'emporter les
français avec nous comme jacques chirac
a su le faire comme nicolas sarkozy ont
su le faire et moi je crois que
l'écologie plus tôt la défense de
l'environnement c'est une grande et
belle épopée pour l'humanité je pense
que nous avons besoin dans notre époque
d'une nouvelle aventure d'une nouvelle
conquête d'une nouvelle épopée je
prononce le bon et je pense que
l'environnement peut être cette nouvelle
épopée et que la droite républicaine a
quelque chose de positif à dire qu'ils
interrogent notre société qui interroge
la notion de progrès qui veille à ce que
nos concitoyens soient plus heureux
demain non pas qu'ils aient le dernier
téléphone à la mode mais qu'ils puissent
se nourrir de manière qualitative qu'ils
puissent élever leurs enfants dans des
conditions d'environnement interroger la
consommation vous voulez dire interrogée
la manière dont on vit dans la société
c'est pas mais est ce que ça veut dire
par exemple de remettre en cause le
déploiement de la 5g
je pense qu'il faut interroger ce sujet
sur la scène g et moi je je je m'épuise
de voir deux formes d'intégrisme se
faire face
l'intégrisme macro nist qui au fond est
incapable de se poser des questions qui
considère que parce que c'est moderne
c'est beau c'est cette espèce de
progressisme permanent qui est une forme
de dictature de la pensée
et puis l'autre intégrismes qui est
celui qui interdirait toute évolution
moi je suis ni pour l'évolution
technologique permanente sans la
questionner qui aboutira un jour ou
l'autre aux autres en humanisme ni pour
la norme pas huile on peut être entre
les deux clairement c'est quoi la
position des républicains sur cet agrès
fallait déployer ou pas écoutez moi je
vous exprime ma position personnelle je
veux pas embarquer l'ensemble de mes
collègues sur ce sujet mais moi je
m'interroge sur la question de la 5g
sans être pour autant un affreux
complotistes ou je ne sais quoi je dis
simplement une chose claire
aujourd'hui nous avons dans notre pays
des centaines de territoire et notamment
dans le lot dans lesquels on n'a pas la
question de la 5g on n'a même pas accès
au téléphone portable et donc je veux
bien qu emmanuel macron duo du 7e
arrondissement de paris nous fasse la
leçon sur la scène joe dante à huile et
commençons à régler les territoires dans
lesquels n'avons même pas accès au
téléphone donc ça veut dire il faut
laisser le temps du débat il faut un
moratoire sur cette question je pense
qu'il moratoire je ne sais pas en tout
les cas il faut en débattre
il faut débattre de cette question du
progrès moi je sais je ne suis pas sûr
de même moi même d'être plus heureux
parce que je vais pouvoir gagner
quelques secondes ou demi seconde à
télécharger mes films préférés
je pense que notre pays est grande sa
littérature est grande et des loisirs
que l'on offre aux femmes et aux hommes
est grande son alimentation et voilà des
sujets qui interroge la consommation
mais quand la droite républicaine dit
par exemple qu'elle est hostile à
l'ouverture des commerces le dimanche
elle le dit parce qu'elle interroge la
question de la consommation et kelly au
fond que nous avons besoin d'un moment
de respiration dans notre semaine je me
l'appliqué à ma génération aussi je leur
dis là aussi sans aucune espèce de
charisme
déroger au tour de france est une vache
sacrée ou pas on peut interroger le tour
de france mais ce que je ne veux pas
c'est que toutes ces interrogations
poussa à chaque fois fouetter les mêmes
c'est à dire les classes populaires
parce qu'au fond derrière ce discours là
et un discours pseudo élitiste cette
idée qu aux fourneaux tour de france et
pour les ploucs et qu'il faut en passer
à autre chose ça je ne le supporte pas
moi je crois en une défense de
l'environnement qui est capable aussi de
permettre à chacun de nos concitoyens de
vivre heureux l'environnement sinistre
ça ne m'intéresse pas allez on va parler
de votre parti des républicains et de ce
sondage ipsos pour le monde sur les
préoccupations des français et on voit
que les sympathisants des républicains
et bien ils placent en tête de leurs
préoccupations
la sécurité le terrorisme et
l'immigration dans des proportions qui
sont même supérieur au chiffre constaté
chez les sympathisants du rassemblement
national le monde a même pointé vous
avez sûrement lu cet article un risque
de poujade isation des militants
républicains ce que vous partagez ce
constat oui enfin je c'est un discours
que j'entends depuis
plusieurs mois et qui sait jamais
vraiment démontré mais qu'est ce qui
était intéressant dans cette étude là
c'est au fond de se demander quel est
l'avenir la droite est ce que l'avenir
des républicains c'est seulement
d'alimenter un fonds de commerce
non parce que ce fonds de commerce il
représente combien l'échelle de la
france
dernières européennes il a représenté
autour de 10%
je le redis l'avenir la droite
républicaine c'est d'embarquer avec nous
dans un même élan une majorité de nos
concitoyens
moi je me suis pas engagé en politique
et dans cette famille politique pour
être seulement le chef d'un clan je me
suis engagé parce que je souhaite que la
droite républicaine porte ses idées pour
l'ensemble de nos concitoyens
vous savez au port-marly il ya quelques
semaines on a fait la rentrée des jeunes
républicains on avait mille jeunes qui
étaient là haut que notre parti n'est
capable de le faire
et durant ces deux journées nous avons
parlé d'écologie nous avons parlé de
croissance
nous avons parlé de démocratie de
matériaux je me souviens a beaucoup
parlé aussi de sécurité oui mais bruno
retailleau a raison de parler de
sécurité mais nous avons eu raison aussi
et ces jeunes n'ayant trouvé un
véritable espoir que nous disions que la
droite républicaine était capable de
porter des vrais des vraies avancées sur
la question du handicap sur la question
des violences conjugales sur ces sujets
qui traversent notre social et
républicain se sont trop enfermé dans
ses questions de sécurité d'immigration
pour vous est sûrement un seul défaut de
tous les partis vous savez il ya un
raisonnement moi qui me stupéfait depuis
quelques temps qui était ce raisonnement
des parts de marché électoral
souvent les réunions on entend ça des
fois il faut qu'on il faut qu'on
s'adresse à notre électorat
enfin on n'est pas un grand parti celui
du général de gaulle de jacques chirac
pour ne s'adresser qu'à notre électorat
mais sinon on continuera à faire 10% aux
élections notre ambition c'est nous
adresser aux français voilà pourquoi je
suis hostile à tout ce qui nourrit tracy
les primaires ces discours binaire je
veux que nous élargissions notre regard
la droite a toujours échoué quand elle
était borgne mais quand on regarde et
les français avec un seul oeil qui était
celui du régalien nous devons aussi
regarder les français en donnant un
espoir mais vous parler de primaires
justement on a du mal à saisir comment
vous allez vous en sortir pour choisir
un candidat pour la présidentielle de
2000 22 et vous avez peu de recul
historique à peine plus âgés que moi
vous savez que jusque là dans l'histoire
politique de notre pays
on a réussi à avoir des candidats aux
présidentielles qui même pour certains
ont été élus sans la primaire moi je
suis stupéfait qu'aujourd'hui on nous
explique au fond que on est né avec la
primaire et qu'on devra mourir avec la
primaire non vous n'y est pas favorable
dans je suis une mère totalement hostile
parce que la primaire elle rétrécit
elle consiste d'abord à être un chef de
clan avant de devenir le chef d'état et
ça ne marche pas et j'ajoute à sac la
primaire un défaut considérable c'est
que elle donne au moindre pépin du coin
la possibilité d'être candidat à la
présidentielle
or être candidat à la présidentielle
c'est une autre affaire que d'être élu à
la primaire sur un malentendu
mais alors il faut quoi un conseil des
sages comme l'évoquent gérard larcher
une élection par des grands élus comme
ça a pu se faire en 1958 pour l'élection
de 2 go justement comment nicolas
sarkozy devient le candidat de la droite
républicaine
ils deviennent incarner la droite
républicaine après qu'il se soit très
tardivement imposée dans l'opinion comme
étant celui qui avait le plus de chances
d'être élu moi j'en appelle à la
responsabilité de chacun j'imagine que y
compris ceux qui ont un talent fou dans
notre famille politique seront capables
d'être lucide sur le fait qu'il y en
aura au final quelques mois avant ou une
qui aura le plus de chance de l'endroit
où on semble en mesure de s'imposer dans
l'opinion mais deux ans avant personnes
ça n'est jamais arrivé que deux ans
avant nous ayons un candidat qui
s'impose
je trouve qu'il ya une forme d'hystérie
autour de ce sujet depuis plusieurs
semaines c'est tout à fait irrationnel
ça n'est jamais arrivé que deux ans
avant nous ayons un par les parents vous
croyez encore à sa candidature pour vous
il a renoncé moi je crois dans une idée
certaine de la fidélité en politique
j'ai une estime considérable pour
françois baroin pour ce qu'il est et
pour les convictions qu'il porte et
principalement pour les convictions qui
portent parce que c'est ce qui compte
pour moi cette vision juste de la
société c'est une vision que j'aime et
j'ai toujours dit que s'il était
candidat je le soutiendrai de toutes mes
forces
la décision lui appartient mais tant
qu'il n'aura pas dit il ne sera pas
candidat je continuerai par fidélité par
honnêteté à dire que je le soutiens
sinon je ne serai pas de ceux qui
parce que la période est fébrile qui
trente navires en se disant il faut
changer de cheval non ils vont se
soigner ces personnes qui au sein de
votre parti sont déjà en train de
changer de changer de cheval qui est qui
qui font des coups de dés qui font des
appels du pied à xavier bertrand déjà
dans le lot nous avons une expression
que j'aime beaucoup on dit que sur le
marché aux bestiaux les premières vaches
qui se vendent ne sont pas les meilleurs
mais l'expression à voler avant la
présidentielle et régionales
est ce que vous serez candidat vous aux
régionales j'ai dit que j'annoncerai ma
décision je vais pas vous faire une
baroin fait dans quinze jours l'occident
est si je vous le dis c'est vraiment que
j'ai encore besoin de réfléchir je le
fais pas par coquetterie je le fais
d'abord parce que j'aime beaucoup cette
région d'occitanie c'est ma région
qu'elle m'a beaucoup donné je sais avoir
à lui rendre aussi beaucoup comme mon
pays m'a beaucoup donné et j'essaie de
le lui rendre
je sais aussi que je n'ai je ne suis pas
frappé de cette urgence d'être candidat
à toutes les élections que l'élection
régionale est une émission engageante et
que je ne veux pas faire semblant
je sais aussi que nous pourrions faire
beaucoup mieux que ce qui est fait
aujourd'hui par la présidente de région
socialistes que le match qui s'installe
entre cette gauche qui n'a pas beaucoup
d'idées et l'extrême droite des énervés
locaux m'inquiète et justement torche
mire et mes responsabilités d'une
manière ou d'une autre c'est qu'on va
regarder un bridage un sondage ifop dans
votre région c'est vous qui avaient été
testées pour pour les républicains alors
certes vous allez me dire on est loin de
l'élection et ce n'est qu'un sondage
mais quels enseignements vous tiré de ce
sondage vous arrivé en troisième
position à 14% et derrière carole delga
dont vous parliez et le la liste du
rassemblement national
est ce que ça vous donne envie d'aller
au combat ou est ce que vous vous dites
c'est ça vaut peut-être pas le coup oh
non c'est parce qu'il guidera ma vision
c'est ici dans le lot on avait fait un
sondage quelques semaines avant
l'élection législative jeu j'aurais
sûrement été donné perdant j'ai toujours
gagné les élections que les sondages
donnaient perdant pense que j'observe
c'est que nous arrivons sans même que je
sois candidat à être devant le ministre
l'agriculture devant la république en
marge qui plutôt une bonne nouvelle dont
je prendrai mes responsabilités ma
décision mais je le ferai avec sincérité
avec respect de mes concitoyens et merci
beaucoup merci aurélien pradié merci
beaucoup je viens d'avoir été avec nous
ce matin demain à votre place ce sera
philippe martinez secrétaire général de
la cgt on passe ensuite au club de
territoire la mutu